le parti lunaire qui s'est tenue à la
saint sylvestre dans un charmant petit
village d'ille-et-vilaine yeux ronds
mais sans doute de grand renom puisque
plus de 2500 topher venus de france de
belgique d'angleterre et d'espagne s'y
sont rassemblés vous le savez une rave
party interdite
une rave party extrêmement bien organisé
puisque les entrées étaient filtrées et
payante puisqu'il y avait des stands de
vente de stupéfiants de nourriture et
d'alcool est extrêmement bien organisés
parce que tout le monde s'est rendu dans
ce lieu
cette rave party lunaire était aussi à
haut risque non seulement sanitaire
monsieur le ministre et nous en avons
parlé puisque les conditions sanitaires
je vous laisse imaginer comment les
choses ont pu se passer c'était une
vraie provocation mais aussi une rave
party à hauts risques en matière de
sécurité vous savez bien monsieur le
ministre
puisqu'un véhicule de gendarmerie a été
incendiée et trois gendarmes ont été
agressés monsieur le ministre
alors la critique est aisée l'art est
plus difficile et je veux très
sincèrement vous remercier de la manière
dont vous avez géré ou siffler en tout
cas la fin de la partie
vous avez su le faire en concertation
avec les élus seulement monsieur
monsieur le ministre la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui vous avez bien géré la
fin
mais comment se fait-il que 2500
teufeurs et peut trouver le lieu d'une
fête qui était extrêmement organisé donc
un lieu non improvisé alors que la
gendarmerie n'a pas pu infiltrer des
réseaux lui permettant de connaître le
lieu d'anticiper car une fois que les
gens étaient là on pourrait pas se faire
sauter les parachutistes sur un lieu de
cette nature
deuxième chose deuxième chose monsieur
minutes
c'est l'incompréhension d'une partie de
la population qui se dit qu'un certain
nombre de français qui sont allés en
suisse faire du ski sont revenus se sont
vu imposer une quarantaine et je partage
la question à vous avec le ministre de
la santé et comment 2500 teufeurs vous
localiser très bien gérer ça comment
ont-ils pu se disperser en france est
dispersé le virus je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur en
deux minutes
madame la sénatrice le président jeudi
devant le ministre breton du
gouvernement permettez moi de vous
corriger ce n'était pas des teufeurs
mais des délinquants qui se sont réunis
ce soir là puisque nous avons établi
dans une manifestation illégale je
rappelle que la loi de la république
c'est plus de 500 personnes c'est
illégal
une version judiciaire d'ailleurs a été
faite par le procureur de la république
et je l'en remercie 2000 verbalisation
2000 verbalisation été mise 15
arrestations -quatre mise en examen il
ya eu saisie de deux tonnes et demie de
matériel et il ya eu 15 murs de sons
qu'on était effectivement saisi puisque
nous avons effectivement fait ce travail
en collaboration avec l'autorité
judiciaire cela n'a pas été un fini il
est vrai madame la sénatrice que je n'ai
pas souhaité contrairement à quelques
bouts de feu qui m'encourageait parfois
sur les réseaux sociaux à la télévision
d'envoyer les parachutistes sur des gens
qui avaient entre 15 et 20 ans dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et je
salue le sang froid des gendarmes et
j'ai préféré effectivement clôturer le
site sous l'autorité du premier ministre
afin qu'il n'y ait eu nulle blessés
nulle décédé je rappelle d'ailleurs que
parmi les jeunes qui étaient présents et
dans des conditions sanitaires que vous
à respecter et de sécurité puisque 225
d'entre eux ont été verbalisés pour
avoir consommé des stupéfiants
cela s'est fait dans des conditions où
l'ordre républicain a été tenue ou les
personnes et les ordinateurs sont
poursuivies dont certains même ont été
incarcérés vous évoquez la question de
comment cela est il possible d'abord
madame la sénatrice
c'est une question que le sénat évoquera
dans les voies renseignements sur
certainement les réseaux
de communication parallèle plutôt que le
téléphone et le sms empêche bien
évidemment le ministère de l'intérieur
qui ne fait qu'appliquer la loi de la
république d'intervenir et nous devons
nous poser la question de savoir comment
dans l'ordre public
nous pouvons désormais prévoir à sa zone
de manifestation de cette ampleur
quand c'est une rave party ça peut nous
choquer quand ce sont des actes de
rassemblement comme les black blocks
ça ne choque d'autant plus que je
demanderai au parlement sous l'autorité
du premier ministre
les moyens de pouvoir se renseigner pour
activer pour activer les forces de
l'ordre